こんちは！はじめしゃちょーです！
お前たち夏といえば何かわかるか？
そう祭りだ！
祭りってのはいろんな祭りがある訳よ！
夏休み間には！
さまざまな祭りが！
各地で！
かなり！
行われている！！
そう！
夏といえば
祭りだ！
まぁ、祭りと言ったら君達何を買いますか？
あれを買うしかないしょ
これはもう決まってる
まぁな、結局な、そうなっちゃうわけなんだよな
こちら！
夏といえばこれだよな
あぁ、間違いない！
祭り、やべっ、ちょっと
俺、ガリガリ　ガリガリだ
は
かき氷を食べると思うんですけども
今回、こちらに王道の三種類を用意したと思うんですけども
こちらの王道の三種類
この三種類がね！
主な王道のかき氷だと思うんですけども
かき氷のフレーバーだと思うんですけども
みんなは何味が好きかな？
僕は迷わずブルーハワイが好きだったんですけども
なんと最近ですね！なんと！なんと！
とんでもない情報を仕入れたわけなんですよ
本当かは、分かんないんですけど
聞いた話だからなんともいえないんですけども
かき氷のシロップ
俺はこれを聞いた時びっくりしたよ
ネットにもほぼ確定てきな情報があったらしくて
裏を見ても原材料名のところ違うのは
色とか色素とかそれ以外は全部成分が同じなので
下手したらね！マジでね
色が違うだけで味が同じなのかも知れません
真実かどうかは俺は知らない
それを確かめるために俺がいるんだろ
もしですよ！もしこれがですよ！3つとも同じ味だったら
祭りの屋台とかでだよ
私何味が好きとか、私この味が好きとか言ってる奴は
ぱっ
色にだまされてますね
それが本当かどうか知んないよ
わかんないので
今日は俺様がね
グラスに３つ入れて
おいらが目隠しをしたまま当てます
俺が当てれたら
てか、毒ゞしくね
当てられたら、シロップによって味は違うかもしれない
でも同じに感じたら、俺たちは今まで
イチゴ味やメロン味が好きだとか言ってた奴ら全員
ぱっ
てことになっちゃうんで
俺ちょっと責任重大だよ
ここで俺がもし
全部同じって言ったら
いろんな人が馬鹿にされちまう
俺は当てるよ
俺はいちご味、メロン味、ブルーソーダ味
ブルーハワイ味ってあるんで
ところでブルーハワイ味ってなんなんすか
ひょっとしたら全部同じなのかもしれないんですけども
とりあえず確かめていこうと
はい、まず味見です
シロップだけで飲むのはじめてだな
これこぼしたら絶対蟻が出る
うわっ
こぼしちゃった
毒ゞしい色ですね、できれば飲みたくないでした（？）
味を一個ずつ覚えて、あとで目隠しして全部当てていきます
メロンのにおいがする
メロンのにおいがする！
あぁ、濃いな
かろうじて、メロンの味はします
メロンだ！メロンの味がする
ブルーハワイ味ってみんな普通に言うけど実際みんなブルーハワイなんて食ったことないしょ
架空の生き物かもしれないですよね
かろうじて、ブルーハワイの味がしますね
ブルーハワイがおいら一番好きなんでブルーハワイの味はします
たぶんいけます
最後
あっ！いちごは分かる
いちごはいちごっぽいわ
いちごはすごい分かりやすい
いちごが一番匂いが強いな
匂いが強いのはいちごです
よし、整いました
お前ら見とけよ
この、シロップマイスターはじめーんがね
いまから全部のシロップの味をね、ちゃんとバッチリ当てますから
色を見ずに味だけでシロップを判断していこうと思います
シャッフルします
はい！そろそろもうほんとに分かんないんで
では、スタートです
これから当てます
はいこの色だよ
いきます！
あっ！いちごではないな
いちごではない
ちょっと飲んでみます
ブルーハワイ！
同じだー！！
ほんとにね、マジで全部同じです
ちょっと無理ほんとに分かんない
おまけで
全部足すと何色になるかやってみたい
うわっ！やべぇ
真っ黒になっちゃった